У багатьох німецьких містах нині
гострий дефіцит житла. Настільки, що уряд ФРН
зобов'язався профінансувати будівництво
1,5 мільйона помешкань у Німеччині
загальною вартістю 6 мільярдів євро впродовж 4 років.
Німецькі забудовники кажуть, що впораються
з таким обсягом. Мовляв, вони будують швидше і
якісніше, ніж у багатьох інших країнах.
У чому їхній секрет роботи?
У німецьких будівельних компаніях пояснюють, що
швидка і злагоджена робота на будмайданчиках –
це лише верхівка айсбергу, результат тривалої
підготовки усіх документів, що може тривати довше року.
Гарун Айдеєр замислився про зведення будинку
одразу після одруження. Оформивши
земельну ділянку під житло, звернувся
до архітектурно-будівельного бюро, яке взяло
на себе підготовку документації та пошук фахівців.
За послуги генерального підрядника Гарун готовий
додатково заплатити кілька тисяч євро.
Але переконаний, що ця інвестиція того вартує.
- Якщо звертатися до будівельників
без фахової освіти, вам доведеться самотужки
занурюватися у все, що стосується кожної стадії
зведення житла: не лише як викласти камінь
на камінь, а й усе щодо геодезії, електрики,
опалення, інженерних конструкцій, тобто стати спеціалістом з усіх цих питань.
Та навіть якщо самотужки імпровізувати
на будмайданчику, проштудіювавши
всі онлайн-форуми і статті, цього, на жаль,
не вистачить, аби швидко збудувати житло.
Це може затягнутися довше двох років.
Оформлення необхідних документів і будівельних дозволів
триває близько півроку. Лише після цього
розпочинають будівництво. Зведення більш-менш
стандартного будинку триває в середньому від 6 місяців до року.
- Оптимально швидка та якісна робота
на будмайданчику можлива, якщо всі дозволи
узгоджені заздалегідь, а графік робіт чітко розписаний:
спершу працює бригада одного підрядника,
далі - іншого. І щоб не довелося нічого переробляти,
всі роботи мають постійно контролювати фахівці.
Не можна покладати всю відповідальність лише на робітників.
Терміни здачі будинку прописані в угоді
про виконання будівельних робіт. Зазвичай
у цій же угоді передбачені штрафи за невчасно або
неякісно виконані роботи, які дисциплінують будівельників.
Що більше "форс-мажорів" передбачено угодою,
то кращі шанси в замовника захистити свої права,
коли щось піде не так.
- Ми платимо підрядникам лише після того, як
фахівці перевіряють і підтверджують, що роботи
виконані належним чином. Скажімо, електрики
виконали всі роботи на 100%. Тоді й можуть
отримувати всю суму оплати. А якщо на 80%, то
вони отримають не більше, ніж 80% від суми нашої угоди.
На підставі такої угоди замовник може притягнути
недобросовісних будівельників до відповідальності
і матиме добрі шанси виграти судовий позов.
Проштрафитися можуть навіть провідні будівельні компанії:
приміром, набиравши забагато проектів, які
здати вчасно неможливо. Або ж не вкладаються
в економний кошторис, якого обіцяли дотримуватись.
- Ми прораховуємо ризики, пов’язані з погодними умовами,
хворобами робітників, затримками доставок матеріалів.
Тож 10-15% додаткового часу вже закладаються
в термін виконання робіт, вказаний в угоді.
Цей резерв дозволяє підрядникам уникати хаосу
на будмайданчиках.
Стандартна будівельна угода передбає також
гарантію на виконані роботи на 4-5 років. Тобто
якщо за цей час відпаде штукатурка або підуть тріщини,
будівельник має власним коштом усунути недоліки.
Іноді банк може навіть упродовж 5 років утримувати
від 3 до 5% від загальної вартості робіт
як страхову заставу на випадок виявлення недоліків у роботі будівельників.
Приміром, якщо контракт на суму 150 000 євро, то
в разі неякісної роботи фірма може недорахуватися 7,5 тисяч євро.
- Якщо частина робіт виконана неякісно,
скажімо, від стін відпадають кахлі, замовник може
взяти ось цей договір і сказати підряднику:
"Отже, ось договір, який я з тобою укладав, і ти
зобов’язався щодо гарантії якості робіт
принаймні на 4-5 років". Усі недоліки мають бути
усунені коштом цього підрядника.
Гарун Айдеєр задоволений темпами підготовки
до будівництва. Вони з дружиною планують заїхати
у власну оселю через рік. А ті, хто не хоче або не може
стільки чекати, дедалі частіше надають перевагу
іншій формі будівництва - модульним будинкам.
Це напівготові конструкції: стіни, вікна, сходи і дах
монтують лише за декілька днів. Аннемарі та її друг Йоша
також обрали модульний будинок. Швидкість робіт
на будмайданчику їх вразила.
- Від підписання договору до початку будівництва
минуло, мабуть, півроку. Це була фаза планування.
Ми були в захваті. Нам не вірилося,
що будівництво нарешті почалося і що, скажімо,
вчора тут ще нічого не було, а наступного дня
ми вже зможемо  стояти в нашому будинку.
На думку деяких будівельних експертів,
фабричні модульні конструкції мають вагомі переваги
і щодо швидкості, і щодо якості. На виробництві
легше контролювати якість робіт та оперативно
враховувати всі побажання замовників.
Архітектори фантазують, що в майбутньому
готові будинки можна буде замовляти з доставкою на будмайданчик, наче піцу.